[Music]
on this wednesday night canada's former
top soldier guilty as charged what
retired general jonathan vance has
admitted to in court and what he's been
sentenced to the prime minister visits a
bc first nation and hears from
residential school survivors
plus this indigenous leader met the pope
in 2009 now phil fontaine's back in rome
why he hopes this trip will be different
world is watching russia breaks its
promise to scale back attacks in ukraine
and germany which relies on russian oil
and gas prepares for rationing bus
strength in numbers more salaries on the
mortgage allow you to buy something
bigger breaking into hot housing markets
without breaking the bank
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the latest chapter in the
downfall of canada's former chief of the
defense staff jonathan vance who served
as top military commander for six years
has pleaded guilty to one count of
obstruction of justice a charge laid
after an investigation into allegations
of sexual misconduct the judge today
called it a serious offense but vance
will not serve any time in jail he was
put on probation and given community
service our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson who first broke the story
about vance was in the courtroom today
canada's former top soldier looked
resigned to his fate as he appeared in
an ottawa courtroom over his iphone
general jonathan vance who once
commanded canada's military now the face
of the sexual misconduct scandal that
has rocked the canadian armed forces
vance spoke few words but told judge
robert wadden he was guilty of
obstruction of justice and wadden
convicted him
in an agreed upon statement of facts
read in court vance admitted to
directing major kelly brennan a
subordinate with whom he had a sexual
relationship to lie to the military
police to cover it up vance failed to
disclose the relationship to the
military and could have faced a charge
under military regulations brennan first
came forward to global news in february
of 2021 alleging sexual misconduct by
vance and told global news he was
pressuring her to mislead investigators
what did he say to you kelly told me to
lie
the crown referenced recordings some of
which were obtained as evidenced by
global news that vance told brennan to
lie the really really really important
thing here
um is that
is that we did not have sex in
toronto
or here in ottawa before the storm
starts i just wanted to make certain
that you're
clear on our story
in his sentencing the judge said
evidence indicated that vance was a man
of good character who still had much to
contribute to society
i don't feel it's necessary to burden
you with a criminal conviction the judge
told vance
vance was granted a conditional
discharge he will serve 12 months of
probation and must complete 80 hours of
community service
if vance complies with those terms he
won't receive a criminal record
the sentence was criticized by advocate
groups and experts in sexual misconduct
who say it sends the wrong message there
was ample evidence he fathered a child
with the victim
has denied it and so there's so much
evidence he pled guilty and
and his colleagues came and supported
him
mckenzie says the judge focused on
vance's career rather than his
transgressions i think the message it
sends to perpetrators and people who are
thinking about perpetrating is make sure
that you have each other's backs in
court today vance's lawyer acknowledged
that vance shares a child with kelly
brennan something vance had previously
denied to global news meanwhile today on
parliament hill defense minister anita
anand refused to comment on vance's
conviction a report by retired supreme
court justice louise arbor is expected
in the coming weeks donna
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thank you prime minister justin trudeau
said today was an honor and a privilege
to be invited to the williams lake first
nation in bc
is there to learn more about the
evidence found in january of 93 unmarked
graves near the site of the former saint
joseph's mission residential school the
prime minister met and listened to
survivors including frank robbins who
started at the school in the early 1960s
when he was five years old i encountered
a lot of
a lot of pain and hurt and you know when
an abused and
you know abused all contributional i
don't think i'll ever get over it i
always say you know i'll go to my grave
with what happened you know i'm never
here
our reporter kamal karamali is in
williams lake covering this visit by the
prime minister kamal was this all about
listening or did the prime minister have
something to offer the first nation
there
it was about listening but the williams
lake first nation also got what else
they were asking for which is funding
for its survivors and the federal
government now contributing or promising
2.9 million dollars to families whose
childrens were
whose children were taken away and sent
to saint joseph's mission residential
school there will be
more phases and more funding to come but
right now the focus on
documenting and finding
the truth
but also on supporting survivors
supporting a community that is being
re-traumatized
the feds had already contributed 1.4
million dollars to help uncover
potential burial sites now this money is
also earmarked to help impossible
excavation on the grounds of the former
residential school here survivors say it
was an emotional day here the pm met
with residential school survivors
followed by a closed door meeting with
those who had attended the former saint
joseph's mission school he saw some
survivors break down as they shared
their stories now media weren't allowed
into that closed door meeting but uh
those inside called it uh incredibly
powerful emotional he apologized face to
face and they had a chance to let
trudeau know of the trauma uh they
continue to face um as for the saint
joseph's mission residential school or
the former site of it the williams lake
first nation said it is working donna
with other communities to possibly
excavate the land there to just
determine conclusively what those
reflections are back over to you all
right kamal karamali in williams lake bc
thanks
a 24-hour crisis line is available to
support residential school survivors the
number is toll-free you can speak in
confidence the number is 1-800-720
a little later we hear from an
indigenous leader who is back in rome
for a second meeting with the pope the
long journey of phil fontaine also a
residential school survivor he tells us
what he hopes this meeting with pope
francis will accomplish
now to ukraine russia's pledge yesterday
to stop shelling certain areas to help
build trust was too good to be true
ukrainian officials say the bombardment
continues near kiev and the northern
city of cherniv the peace talks changed
nothing and today the white house said
it believes it's increasingly clear
russia's invasion has been a strategic
blunder and that vladimir putin is being
misinformed by his advisers about how
badly the russian military is performing
redmond shannon reports and a warning
some of the images in his story are
disturbing
the governor of the chernhiv region in
northern ukraine describing a night of
air strikes just hours after russia said
it would drastically scale back attacks
there and in kiev the capital's mayor
had a similar message
yesterday information right now the
russian forces move
uh away from keith it's not true whole
night we listen to sirens this means the
wreckage attack few insider outside
ukraine are surprised by the broken
promise i don't think you can trust what
is coming out of the mouth of putin's
war machine ukraine's neutrality
proposal coming out of tuesday's talks
in istanbul apparently not enough for
russia
moscow's chief negotiator saying the two
sides are still far apart on the future
of crimea and donbass reports wednesday
say u.s intelligence believes russian
president vladimir putin was misinformed
about the extent of russia's military
struggles on the ground
this village near harkev now back under
ukrainian control according to the
regional governor
we are pushing them back slowly but
steadily says this soldier but in
battered and surrounded marijuana a
different story and a demand from putin
that a ukrainian surrender is the best
way to save the tens of thousands of
people stuck in the city the un says
russia's actions there may amount to war
crimes people are living in sheer terror
the situation is worsening by the day
with constant shelling
president vladimir zelinski is demanding
europe shut all its seaports to russian
ships just as russia has blocked ports
like mariupol his u.s counterpart joe
biden has pledged an additional half a
billion dollars in aid
some of it for humanitarian aid for
mariupol evacuees like dima
he cries out for his father both were
injured in shelling and are now in
different hospital wards all the nurse
can do is assure him his dad will come
soon redmond shannon global news london
this holocaust memorial is among the
many sites hit by russian shelling
according to ukraine's ministry of
defense it's on the outskirts of the
second largest city harkev the monument
in the form of a giant menorah has lost
two of its seven branches was built 20
years ago it's a tribute to more than 16
000 jewish people who were killed by the
nazis from december of 1941 to january
1942.
the exodus of refugees from ukraine has
now grown to more than 4 million people
according to the u.n refugee agency and
unicef says half of them are children
neighboring poland has by far taken in
the most refugees more than 2.3 million
followed by romania moldova and hungary
russia's war on ukraine is having
repercussions around the world oil
prices after reaching a 10-day low
yesterday because of hope about peace
talks climbed throughout the day today
and germany which relies on gas and oil
from russia is preparing for an energy
crisis activating an emergency plan and
warning the public gas rationing could
be coming eric sorenson reports
home stove in germany probably burning
russian natural gas
and the same for germany's big companies
this fiber producing plant employs 600
but depends on natural gas when we're
here kind of guys without gas says the
plant director we have to shut down
economic sanctions may bring hardship to
russia
but europe and germany in particular
will absorb the fallout from russian gas
shortages prices have already shot up
and supply cuts would make things worse
um
germany's economy minister has announced
an early warning for his country a first
step before an emergency that could
force rationing for homes and businesses
germany is essentially preparing for a
worst-case scenario here in which supply
is completely cut off at least from the
east much of russia's natural gas is
extracted in arctic siberia pipelines
deliver most of it directly to western
europe because of russia's attack on
ukraine germany has stopped one new
pipeline the nordstream 2 just built
under the baltic sea but germany's
dependence is enormous importing an
estimated 43 billion cubic meters from
russia in all the eu gets more than 40
percent of its natural gas imports from
russia
vladimir putin is now demanding payments
in rubles to prop up the russian
currency and that could trigger an early
standoff with europe
this economist is advising germans to
get off natural gas as much as possible
before demand spikes again next winter
it could get more expensive says this
man but it's necessary to put the
aggressor in his place still the
economic effects felt in europe will
likely ripple around the world including
to canada this is delivering a shock to
european households so overall you're
looking at a hit to consumer pocketbooks
on a global basis and a rise in
inflationary pressures that will almost
certainly push central banks farther in
the tightening direction than they
wanted to go in other words disrupting
natural gas supplies in far away siberia
could speed up higher interest rates
over here
eric sorensen global news toronto
a revelation about a hollywood star's
health coming up why bruce willis is
stepping away from acting
in the u.s the president said today
covet 19 no longer controls the lives of
americans but at the same time joe biden
got a fourth dose of vaccine and
epidemiologists are keeping an eye on
hospitalizations as the ba2 variant
becomes the dominant strain jackson
proskow on how the u.s is navigating
this stage of the pandemic
a day after the u.s authorized second
booster shots for those over age 50
president joe biden rolled up his sleeve
and made a fresh pitch to americans
we're now in a new moment in this
pandemic
does not mean that covet 19 is over
it means that covet 19 no longer
controls our lives that's what it means
fourth shots are now seen as the best
defense for older and more vulnerable
people in the u.s they're rolling out at
a confusing time case numbers have
plummeted hospitalizations are at their
lowest point in two years it's hard to
tell people that doing something now is
really going to help you
weeks months maybe even years down the
line
there's reason for concern the omicron
ba2 subvariant is now dominant in the
u.s and cases are starting to tick back
up yet millions remain vulnerable
undeterred by the nearly 1 million
pandemic deaths to date today less than
70 percent of eligible americans are
fully vaccinated with two doses and only
46.5 percent have received a booster
dose this really does beg the question
where should we focus our limited
resources is it on providing fourth
doses or is it on other measures for
example making sure we vaccinate people
who may not have even had a single dose
yet
at the same time the once world-leading
u.s response has effectively run dry
congress has not approved funding to
cover the cost of future covid testing
treatment or vaccine doses congress has
to provide the funding america needs to
continue to fight cuba 19. yet it may be
tough to convince americans to keep up
the fight
two years in and during a welcome
reprieve in cases many feel like they're
done with the pandemic even if it's not
done with them
jackson prosko global news washington
one of hollywood's biggest stars bruce
willis is stepping away from acting
after being diagnosed with a condition
called aphasia which robs people of the
ability to communicate the 67 year old
is famous for blockbusters like die hard
his family says he was recently
diagnosed with aphasia and it's
impacting his cognitive abilities the
condition can occur after a stroke or
head injury his family says as bruce
always says live it up and together we
plan to do just that
there is no eye in down payment ahead
the team effort to buy into canada's hot
housing market
real estate analysts say home prices
across canada are about 50 percent
higher now than before the pandemic and
that is making it especially hard for
first time buyers one way to break into
the hot market is to do it collectively
through co-ownership it's a growing
trend in expensive urban centers and
gaviola explains how it works
this 3000 square foot duplex with two
separate dwellings under one roof sold
in march 2021 to four friends they
pulled their resources to afford the two
million dollar semi-detached home close
to transit and with a backyard more
people having down payment more salaries
on the mortgage allow you to buy
something bigger homeownership is split
50 50 between the two couples each
couple contributed a 200 000 down
payment now all of this is possible with
advanced planning lots of legal
documents and agreements before moving
in and monthly house meetings plus two
social meetings every week when
schedules permit those are a bit more
casual we do them over dinner
we cook each other dinner one night a
week and those are kind of spaces to
come together and chat these four
millennial buyers whose annual pay
ranges from 60 to 120 000
are part of a growing trend in the most
expensive urban centers toronto-based
co-ownership company arboro has seen a
nearly 400 percent surge in interest in
their services this year compared with
the end of last year some trying to get
ahead of rising interest rates others
looking to get into a market they can't
access on their own when they learn
about it they they feel like
where has this been kind of all my life
these co-owners are celebrating one year
since they purchased their home together
and they have this advice for people
considering this path it takes time and
it takes it does take effort but i think
there's a huge payoff
be honest with yourself first and what
your needs are because in co-housing it
can get really easy if that's something
you're thinking about to people please
or you know go with the group you know
it increases affordability it increases
options for them
and it helps build community and i think
leads to a to a richer and more
fulfilling life
an increasingly popular alternative for
those feeling priced out of the housing
market ann caviola global news toronto
the long road to reconciliation next
what a former chief of the assembly of
first nations hopes to achieve on his
return to rome
a great deal is riding on the meetings
between indigenous leaders and pope
francis this week residential school
survivors and their families have waited
years for an apology from the catholic
church one of those survivors is phil
fontaine the former national chief of
the assembly of first nations
reconciliation healing and forgiveness
are his life's work and as crystal
gomezing reports he's been to the
vatican before he's hoping this trip
will be different
phil fontaine has been tirelessly
navigating a painful and long journey to
hold power to account
what's the wealth what's the power lots
of influence for more than 30 years this
survivor of canada's government and
church-run residential school system has
been present for every major step in the
reckoning of harms inflicted on first
nation inuit and metis children when
fontaine first began sharing his
experiences
the abuses children like him lived
through at those schools were only
whispered into the ears of confidance he
went public to inspire others to step
out of the shadows while demanding a
full systematic review it was clear to
me
that the
the story of the residential school
experience had to be told we had to
have
uh our stories
the experience recorded there are now
volumes of first-hand accounts they have
been recorded and shared a required step
for healing it's why the truth and
reconciliation commission was
established it's also the point behind
wanting an official papal apology during
a similar delegation visit in 2009
sorrow was expressed
this one
has such promise
and
great expectations the discovery of
hundreds of unmarked graves in bc and
saskatchewan last year forced the world
to think of the children who died and
the families who have been left
wondering what happened to their lost
loved ones the world was watching the
world is watching while survivors say
it's about securing a place for future
generations the next generation
including fontaine's daughter and her
children
are also looking back
and my sincere wish is he gets
the apology that's so important to him a
wish for a man who helped get a nation
talking and for all of those who didn't
have the opportunity to share their
stories
crystal gomencing global news
rome
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with more from the williams lake
first nation
the community there like so many others
continues to investigate evidence of
unmarked graves near the site of a
former residential school and need the
government and the church provide
complete records
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
bye
[Music]